how his mother had been oh it is the
absolute best I have never experienced
this kind of love before and though
awesome it's so fulfilling mm-hmm so
your your husband plays baseball so I'm
not a huge sports ball fan I call it
sports ball for a reason but the guys on
my staff have been fangirling over your
husband all day recently pitches is it
third no-hitter yeah third no-hitter
[Applause]
yes I think he's like one of three
people to ever have more than two
no-hitters like ever that's crazy so
he's super good too okay that's insane
when were you there when it happened
I was I was actually on vacation you
know you're like I hope you're having
fun but I'm at the beach that's so cool
okay sports ball you get yeah okay okay
but you're married to Natalie are y'all
competitive or super competitive we
actually can't be on separate teams on
anyway you'll get a fight you'll
probably get two fours so like we only
pinpoint on each other and we're like
okay it's on you and me and that's it no
one else is there in any group games
okay Kate we have to have a game night
at some point cuz I am a die-hard gamer
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this